while we are clearly in better shape
than three years ago when this pandemic
first hit
the global Collective response is once
again under strain
there's no question things have improved
in Canada but would you consider the
kova 19 pandemic over for me personally
I always like try to keep my distance
but it's not like something that affects
my everyday life ask around it's a mixed
bag
it's because people are still getting
sick
sure
yeah
it's over we're starting to have a lot
of fun but people are still getting sick
I just had covered like a couple weeks
ago definitely not over unfortunately my
wife is just getting over it in January
2020 The Who emergency committee decided
covid-19 was a public health emergency
of international concern for some
countries that title has helped justify
and direct how resources are used to
prevent further infection so when does a
shift to an endemic happen this may have
a significant impact if it's downgraded
it may end up being used as
justification by certain governments to
withdraw resources that are allocated to
covet experts say they hope any change
in designation doesn't lull people into
thinking covet is over there is no
off-ramp to kovit kovid will be with us
for the measurable future plus moving
towards an endemic does not come without
risk and and I would encourage us all
that if you haven't had your your
bivalent shot go out and get it do not
underestimate this virus
it has and will continue to surprise us
and it will continue to kill
Catherine Ward Global News